This is called high pressure on the other hand.
Yes, yes, that's
what they say.
That's what the teacher said. No, it's the same day. Well, I
did the book. Uh, the
story of getting 5 points.
Thoroughly cruise the opponent.
Um, ah,
I'm fine, but the situation is unfair.
15-2. If there
is one, it's
frozen.
Really, you're mixing it up.
Uh, yes, it's a
sumo underground passage.
Definitely come with another pen case.
That's it.
Ah, yes,
I'm, yes,
article. Yes, my
brother, what's up
? What do you think? I
have it.
But the
homeroom teacher said this is, far, no, there are a lot of them. It's not like this. Yes, Ah, putting your weight on it. Hmm, no, you're getting married a little early in May.
Yeah, what are you talking about? It's
good.
Hmm,
it's Bamboo Aki, right?
Please, it's easy to see.
And yes, maintain it. A, after
all, Iwanaridai is
weak.
There's a cheek, so before the race, it's,
well, you know. The will, um, you
can't just go,
so you get the top 5 on page 9.  I
want to leave it like this.
What do you think?
This will be the rear guard.
And wow,
you know, if both of us have
no desire for metal, it will
be enough. I don't think so.
But, Keido, making up for what never
happened, what is the
point of High Lark Mochi? Well,
by the tail,
this one is sticking out, yes,
after all, one, I
say,
there is a public offering,
only to guard myself, one,
everyone,
yo
[music],
taste,
other than Bush, I
headed in that direction, I'm running this
kind of company,
yes, poop
beach, yes, it's like
this, you can't get it
anytime,
oil flash,
making memories, that's, I
think Ogura is pretty good too, or rather, yes, so, yes, so as a
workshop, yes, it was here, gigazine,
yes, I'm the sea, I
still
don't understand, it's not the way to go,
boil for 15 minutes
[music] [
music]